[Musica]
[Applauso]
settembre 2009 è una splendida mattina
di sole e io sto andando in università
per finire la ricerca su un materiale
che avevo appena inventato
sì
il mio lavoro ma soprattutto il mio
divertimento e inventare materiali
principalmente nanocompositi ad alte
prestazioni
parola un po da nerd che in realtà sta a
significare semplicemente che sfrutto
materie prime molto molto piccole
un milione di volte più piccole di un
millimetro che inserite in una matrice
più grossolana generano reazioni non
convenzionali
e nel 2009
stavo finendo la ricerca sul primo di
questi durante l'ultimo anno di
dottorato i materiali per l'ingegneria
all'università di brescia
è un intonaco che commercializza ancora
oggi per affrontare i problemi di
umidità nei muri
e i risultati che avevo tenuto erano
molto promettenti il materiale
funzionava bene molto bene
e poi sinceramente
mi ero stufato di studiare
non vedevo l'ora di trasformare in start
up la mia invenzione
ma quella soleggiata mattina di autunno
mi stava aprendo a un futuro totalmente
inaspettato che mi avrebbe consegnato
dodici anni dopo la scoperta di un altro
materiale che avrebbe cambiato in
maniera radicale il modo di consolidare
gli edifici in muratura contro i
terremoti
il laboratorio
tra una prova e l'altra
passavo il mio tempo in sala ristoro per
bere un caffè fare due chiacchiere con
amici e colleghi
quella mattina il direttore di
dipartimento di prendimi dice
stefano ho visto i risultati preliminari
del tuo dottorato sono molto
interessanti se vuoi possiamo
approfondirli inserendo questo materiale
all'interno di un campagna prove che sto
portando avanti io stiamo studiando la
reazione dei materiali durante i
terremoti
però
avremo i primi risultati tra non meno di
otto mesi
professore ringrazio tantissimo nella
proposta io tra un mese ho finito e poi
di sismica non mi occupo
infatti io sono ingegnere meccanico ai
tempi la sismica non avevo mai studiata
esco da quella sala ristoro ma non
riesco a togliermi dalla testa quel
colloquio
vado a casa decido di studiare alcuni
articoli scientifici pubblicati da quel
professore e ci dormo sopra o meglio ci
provo ma non dormo
ero stato contaminato
le mie idee erano state contaminate
ibridate da conoscenze a me
completamente sconosciute ma per questo
interessantissima
sta di fatto che il giorno dopo vado
dalla mia responsabile di dottorato e le
dico
a poche settimane dalla fine che volevo
una proroga ma mi guarda con occhio un
po stralunato ma alla fine dopo un breve
colloquio accetta e mi concede un anno
in più di dottorato
il dado era tratto la mia start up
avrebbe dovuto attendere per proseguire
la ricerca in un settore che non
conoscevo per dei risultati che non
avevo nemmeno chiari
avevo chiara però una cosa
sapevo inventare materiali
ero nel posto giusto per farlo
perché l'università e terra fertile per
continuare a farsi contaminare e
sfruttare quelle conoscenze da inserire
per la costruzione di un nuovo materiale
che ero certo di poter inventare
dopo pochi mesi di ricerca ormai le mie
idee erano ben radicate e gli obiettivi
erano chiari
peccato che ogni volta che mi
confrontavo con i miei colleghi mi
dicevano stefano
non sai nulla di sismica
un intonaco non potrà mai resistere un
terremoto
lascia stare che è meglio
e avevano ragione
io la sismica non la conoscevo per
fortuna per fortuna altrimenti avrei
avuto la mente piena di preconcetti
assunzioni che non avrebbero permesso
alla mia creatività di potersi esprimere
al massimo
ma
cos'è che ho inventato
cos'ha di così innovativo questo
materiale
ecco
perché garve lo volevo fare una slide
illuminante ma non ci sono riuscito
e allora ho chiesto ai miei tre figli di
6 di dieci anni di farlo a loro per me
giovanni anna lucia
potete fare un disegno di una casa
durante un terremoto
e questo risultato è eccezionale
eccezionale perché per noi ricercatori
un terremoto può essere scomposto tra
un'accelerazione orizzontale alla base
dell'edificio è un accelerazione
verticale
per studiare il comportamento di un
edificio durante un terremoto quindi
dobbiamo focalizzarci sull'accelerazione
orizzontale perché l'accelerazione
l'edificio ha già costruito per
resistere i carichi verticali
vorrei farvi notare che i miei figli
hanno segnato soltanto l'accelerazione
orizzontale dei soliti bene direi
quindi il terremoto muove la terra
orizzontalmente e di conseguenza
l'edificio si deforma
fino a rimarrà collasso
ma queste sono informazioni note da
secoli come affrontare questa situazione
per capirlo dobbiamo tornare alla
contaminazione delle idee
infatti durante la mia ricerca
avevo scoperto due cose apparentemente
separate che però mi avevano fatto
accendere nella testa una piccola
lampadina
il primo di questi era l'esistenza dei
calcestruzzi fibrorinforzati per il
consolidamento delle gallerie frc in
inglese
cos'hanno di così bello questi materiali
in realtà voi dovete considerarli come
un calcestruzzo normale che però
all'interno ha delle grandissime il film
di acciaio che sono disperse in maniera
caotica all'interno dell'impasto
queste fibre danno al materiale un
comportamento che noi chiamiamo i
ricercatori temiamo includente sta a
significare che quando comincia rompersi
aumenta la sua resistenza
queste sono informazioni questa
tecnologia è nata circa 25 anni fa e per
mia fortuna
l'università di brescia tra le massime
espressioni mondiali nella loro ricerca
applicata
la seconda cosa che avevo imparato era
il fatto che gli edifici in muratura che
sono l'oggetto della mia ricerca
avessero una resistenza alla
deformazione
praticamente nulla per capirci bastavano
pochi millimetri di spostamento
l'edificio andava in collasso
e per di più
il terremoto si focalizzava in alcuni
punti specifici della nostra casa
tipicamente negli spigoli delle aperture
delle finestre delle porte quando questi
cedevano la casa andava instabilità e
rischiava il collasso
e qui la mia idea
volevo inventare un materiale includente
a basso spessore che resistesse di più
mentre se non beva per capirci volevo un
materiale che man mano che si rompeva
aumentava le sue caratteristiche
meccaniche
che è esattamente l'opposto di qualsiasi
introna col oggi in commercio
ma
come fare a ottenere questo risultato
abbiamo una
abbiamo fatto una serie di ricerca in
laboratorio e
alla fine dopo dieci anni
siamo riusciti a ottenere questo
risultato e due anni fa per la
conclusione della nostra ricerca abbiamo
fatto un test sperimentale in scala
reale
abbiamo costruito una casa di due piani
e l'abbiamo sollecitata con due
terremoti
il primo senza materiale
il secondo con l'intonaco
ecco
i risultati che abbiamo ottenuto sono a
dir poco entusiasmanti per capire però
concedetemi una breve spiegazione
altrimenti non si capisce
quando noi costruiamo una casa qui in
italia
dobbiamo
dobbiamo studiarla con alcuni parametri
primo fra tutti l'accelerazione alla
base
se vogliamo costruire una casa in zona 1
che è la più pericolosa qui in italia e
spoleto è zona 1
l'accelerazione alla base che dobbiamo
usare per costruire questa casa e 0,35 g
ecco
focalizzatevi su questo numero 0,35 g
torniamo alla nostra casetta
il primo test senza materiale
ha portato il collasso della casa con
un'accelerazione di 0,25 g e uno
spostamento al secondo piano di 3 mm
vi do un altro parametro che così capite
di cosa stiamo parlando e durante il
terremoto dell'aquila del 2009
l'accelerazione media che era subito la
terra è stata 0,50 g
ne in un paese qui vicino in questa
bellissima terra norcia l'accelerazione
alla base è stata 0,36 g quindi
presumibilmente la nostra casetta che ha
riscritto 0 25 gli sarebbe collassata
il secondo test
sulla casa precedentemente lesionata
abbiamo applicato 2,5 cm di spessore
sulle facciate esterne dell'edificio e
basta
l'accelerazione
l'accelerazione che ha subito la casa è
stata
1,47 g
e una deformazione a secondo impalcato
quindi a sei metri di 23 centimetri
questo significa che aumentato di sei
volte quasi l'accelerazione è di otto
volte la deformazione applicando
soltanto 25 centimetri di materiale
sulle facciate esterne sì perché io
volevo studiare un materiale che
forse facile da applicare e
avesse una grande superficie qual è la
superficie più grande che c'è negli
edifici gli intonaci e quindi la mia
idea era studiare questo materiale
includente soltanto da applicare sulle
facciate esterne degli edifici togliendo
l'intonaco vecchio e mettendo
sull'intonaco
qui vedete il quadro fessurativo del
test fatto sulla casetta non intonacata
vedete ci sono poche crepe localizzate
che portano al collasso l'edificio
questo è lo stesso test fatto sulla casa
intonacata quello che voi vedete è la
continua ridistribuzione degli sforzi
data dal materiale che permette a tutta
la superficie della casa di assorbire
l'energia sismica
portando a oltre sei volte il valore di
assorbenti di assorbimento
portare avanti idee non convenzionali
non è semplice
bisogna scontrarsi quotidianamente con
lo scetticismo dei propri colleghi che
pensano che tu non ce la possa fare
etiche non anche un po matto
e degli investitori che hanno
naturalmente più difficoltà a investire
in progetti innovativi e non
convenzionali
nel terremoto dell'aquila e del centro
italia
il 94 per cento degli edifici
lesionati
e ancora in piedi
ma è inagibile
questo significa che
130.000 famiglie non possono entrare più
nelle loro case danni
pensate se esistesse una tecnologia che
in due tre in poche settimane gli
interventi permettesse la maggior parte
di queste persone di poter rientrare
nelle proprie case
bene questa tecnologia c'è è nata
tramite la contaminazione delle idee
quella
splendida mattina nel 2009 la mia mente
era pronta per essere contaminata
se voi
permettete all'ignoto a non conosciuto
di entrare in voi senza preconcetti e la
peggiore delle ipotesi imparerete
qualcosa di nuovo
ma potreste anche scoprire qualcosa che
potrebbe avere un impatto
piccolo grande nel mondo
a me è successo proprio questo
senza quella contaminazione
non avrei mai potuto avere la
possibilità
potenzialmente di salvare milioni di
vite nel mondo e dare nuove speranze
alle popolazioni colpite dai terremoti
persone come voi che
vivete in questa splendida ma
pericolosissima terra
[Applauso]